Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P. We
we were talking about racism
at the workplace last week,
and the eggman called in. I guess the eggman
mostly works with racist people. And here are
his observations, which I find pretty interesting.
Speaker 5: Hi, Dave. I was really interested in
you discussing how very racist people handle their
jobs at work. I just want to say that I work at a
company that has mostly racist people, and I will
give you my deduction on that. The more racist
they are, the nicer they are to the black people
and minorities inside the shop behind the back,
N-word, N-word all day long. But when a black
African-American people or Puerto Rican Hispanics
show up, they are the friendliest to them. My wife
thinks it's because they're scared of them. No,
I'm not extra friendly to black people. I'm not
extra mean to black people. I'm just normal to
everybody, but racist people in the public
and jobs. They hide it very well because in
their minds, they're afraid of other racists,
so they act extra sweet. It really irritates me
to see them being nice to these black
people and minorities that I work with,
and I know they just use the word it was
with me before and now they act all buddy,
buddy. I think it's totally disgusting. Shallow
brother. Oh, also in the printing industry,
most people are racist and it has nothing to do
with their job because they do a great job and
then taking the N-word all day long. Wow.
Speaker 1: I didn't realize the printing
industry was so plagued with with racism.
That's very interesting. You know,
I did growing up and growing up. I
mean, you know, late teens, early 20s,
I had someone in my circles who was quite racist
privately and they were insanely polite whenever
there were black or what I would call notably
Hispanic people around. As many of you know,
I'm Hispanic by most definitions. But when I'm
saying brown people when there were black and
brown people around this racist person in my in my
circle who is not part of it anymore, it was not
my friend. They were notably polite to minorities,
and the man's theory or hypothesis is it's because
they're scared. They don't want to get hurt by the
minority, so they become extra polite. Interesting
insights from the eggman we have. A really great
bonus show for you today, we are going to talk
about the sad news of comedian and full house
star and all around good guy from what I know,
Bob Saget, dead at 65, found dead in a hotel room.
You won't be shocked that it is leading to COVID
conspiracies, COVID vaccine conspiracies, but
we'll talk about what is actually known about it.
The James Webb Space Telescope is fully
deployed. Great, so it's all set, right?
No. Now it's five months of configuration and
adjustments and calibration, but we'll tell
you what's going on. It's super interesting
and this is just insane. New York Mayor Eric
Adams has been in the job for a few days. He
has appointed his brother to a $240000 job
that from what I've looked at, his brother is not
qualified for. We'll dig into that in more detail,
but that's my early assessment. Not qualified
for the job. How do you get access to the bonus
show? Very easy. Sign up on my website. Join
Packman dot com. We have a membership program.
We are fully demonetized on Facebook for the
next 90 days, so we really need your help.
Please sign up at join Packman dot com
and we will see you on today's project.